[Music]  the multiverse it's dangerous  i could use an avenger  it's about time you showed up  on may 6th  enter a world  of strange try not to break the  multiverse stephen  oh come on  dr strange in the multiverse of madness  making pg-13 you can see it in premium  large format in imax tickets on seal now  every night  i dream the same dream  then  the nightmare begins  i did what i had to do  to protect our world  you cannot control everything strange  you opened the doorway between universes  and we don't know who or what will walk  through it  wanda  what do you know about the multiverse  this had his theories  he believed it was dangerous  he was right  i'm sorry stephen  your desecration of reality  [Music]  we should tell him the truth  [Music]  things just got out of hand  [Music]  you break the rules look out  and become a hero  i do it i become the enemy  [Music]  that doesn't seem fair  [Music]  [Music]  you